bientôt ces cônes deviendront des
chapeaux evelyne couture à réalise elle
même à la main chacune des étapes
après avoir trempé le feutre dans la
gomme arabique et laisser sécher pendant
plusieurs heures place au moulage donc
le principe est de lundi beac hfo
humides et de passer le faire une fois
ramolli le feu reprend la forme du moule
une technique apprise auprès d'un
meilleur ouvrier de france depuis 2012
cette habitante de chevreuse créé ses
propres chapeau j'ai une formation de
fleuriste
j'ai tenu un magasin de fleurs dans le
sud-ouest et ça m'a amené à créer des
bijoux de cheveux avec des fleurs
naturelles
j'ai une demande de plus en plus
fréquente de clientes qui voulaient
accessoirisé leur leurs tenues certaines
femmes voulaient être chapeauté ce qui
revient à la mode aussi de ce chat potté
soie sauvage toile de jouy dentelle de
calais amoureuse des belles matières
evelyne réalise plus de 300 chapeau par
an pour des cérémonies ou des cocktails
chacun d'eux est unique je travaille sur
mesure et là je je travaille donc dû
du sisal tressé qui est une matière
italienne sur lequel je fais une
décoration adapté à la à la robe de la
mariée
un savoir-faire à découvrir lors du
salon des métiers d'art à rambouillet la
créatrice exposera avec une cinquantaine
d'artisans les 26 et 27 mai